foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth find work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Kim starts off
this hour in Jacksonville Florida hi Kim
Welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks thanks for taking my call how
are you better than I deserve how can we
help
um well to the point of the question um
is there ever an exception
to start investing before you're out of
debt why
um
so I'm an RN I've always worked w
last year I started as a
formed an LLC and I'm filing as f-corp
and my CPA is telling me that I need to
invest for retirement because I'm not
contributing to Social Security and for
the tax deduction
but we have my husband and I have about
24 000 in debt right now okay
um your your CPA does not need to be
giving you advice on this because he's
not very smart
um the
you are paying uh Social Security it's
called self-employment tax
it's 15.3 percent
okay you don't get out of Social
Security uh unless you are a pastor who
opted out uh for as a conscientious
objector but you don't have that option
and I don't either so we get to pay that
uh when you're self-employed you pay
both sides of Social Security uh that's
because the government loves small
business and they want to double dip on
you and so you get to pay 15.3 so you're
doing that uh so your CPA is wrong uh
then secondly you guys are young clean
up your freaking debt so you have some
money to invest
yes um so we started listening to your
show a few weeks ago and I just got your
Total Money Makeover books so we'll
we're working on it is he kind of trying
to scare you into thinking that you're
running out of time because you haven't
started investing yet
well and that's not entirely true um
when I had my W-2 jobs when I worked in
hospitals I do have a 403b and a 401k
okay yeah and how I mean look I tell
folks this all the time with my husband
and I it took us seven years to get out
of all of our debt and we didn't invest
during that time
We Didn't Start investing until our
mid-30s and do you know what we are
perfectly fine
yeah we're fine you've got you've got
the time because here's the thing once
that debt's cleaned up you're gonna have
more money than ever to invest anyway
and you're gonna make up the difference
here's the other possibility he may be
wanting you to invest to save on your
taxes
to create a a pre-tax investment which
is not the best way for you to invest in
right now you need to be doing Roth
which is an after-tax investment gives
you zero tax benefit today but it grows
100 tax-free and so never do a a pre-tax
investment to save on taxes today
because 96 percent of what will be in
your account at your age when you get to
65 will be growth four percent will be
what you put in and took a tax deduction
on and it's a hundred percent taxable if
you do it his way and uh ninety six
percent of it has no taxes on it and
four percent already had the taxes paid
on it if you do it my way with the Roth
so again your CPA needs to stick to
taxes and not Financial advice because
he's not very good at it
there we go
aggravates me so here's the thing let's
go back for a second because it's worth
talking about
um to say
many years ago way back when the
dinosaurs roamed the Earth in the 1980s
the tax law changed and uh to stimulate
the economy they put in unbelievable tax
advantages on real estate then they took
them away
when they took them away a whole bunch
of people went broke because they bought
the real estate for tax reasons only not
for good math reasons otherwise the only
reason they did the real estate deals
was for tax they were bad real estate
deals
except for the tax and that's what this
is this is a bad investment deal that
he's suggesting except for the tax if
he's suggesting or she's suggesting a
traditional IRA or a traditional 401K
versus a Roth for some young person like
this that's mathematically bullcrap yeah
we would always say to do a match first
right Dave match beats Roth beats
traditional
exactly that's how it works hey guys if
you're planning to move soon and you
know so you can you know it can really
be expensive we got great news for you
our studio sponsor PODS moving and
storage
wants to help someone out there
one of you move for free
get a quote for moving at pods.com
Ramsay between February 20th and March
the 3rd and you're automatically entered
to win no purchase is necessary you're
getting a quote on your move between
February 20th and March the 3rd now
here's what's going to happen someone
that gets those quotes we're going to do
a drawing one listener is going to get a
free move valued at up to five thousand
dollars and ten thousand dollars card
Cold Hard Cash
uh that's a value of 15 grand pods makes
moving easier with the flexibility you
need the control you want the customer
service you deserve this is a great
company they are Ramsay trusted this is
why we brought them on as the Ramsay
Studio sponsor and say their name at the
top of every hour as we enter into
serving you guys because they serve you
go to pods.com Ramsay enter for a chance
to win a free move and ten thousand
dollars cash that's a fifteen thousand
dollar value no purchase necessary just
get a bid on your upcoming move that's
pods.com
Ramsay makes all kinds of sense this is
the way to go open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five circling back to match first Roth
second traditional third you do all of
do those in that order if you're a
married couple it doesn't matter who's
401K we're doing it with we take all the
match we can get first because it
matches a hundred percent rate of return
free money you can't mess this up
if your mutual fund makes a 10 or 11
return that's great when your boss puts
in a hundred percent that's a match
that's a hundred percent rate of return
you really can't screw that up okay and
here's the thing 82 percent of the
companies that offer a 401k offer some
form of match now so always take
advantage full advantage of the match
when you get to baby step four only when
you get to baby step four and when you
get to baby step four you won't have any
payments so you'll have money to put 15
of your household income into that
that's right then from there we do the
Roth and we do the Roth because it's tax
free that's right so when you go to pull
the money out in retirement you're not
paying taxes on it yeah so if you save
up a million two million dollars it's
going to be a hundred percent zero tax
when you're taking it out that's right
what you put in was already taxed and
the growth is a hundred percent tax free
and with the new secure act there is no
required minimum distribution on roths
when you turn to 73. oh I love that you
have to record your required minimum
distribute Solutions on your retirement
if you turn 73 and you have traditional
you have to begin taking it out because
they want their freaking tax money
that's why they do that this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America now it's tax
time yuck a lot of people got questions
about taxes let's unpack a question from
one of our listeners what's the
difference between smiling single and
filing head of household is one better
than the other okay if you're divorced
you're legally separated you're widowed
or you're not married you can file
single and you probably should three
qualifications to file as head of
household you pay more than half of your
household expenses you're unmarried
and you have a qualifying child or
dependent so if you're a single parent
taking care of an aging family member
you might qualify to file as head of
household which by the way if you do
will probably help you on your taxes
probably save your money so filing a set
of household comes with Benefits lower
tax rate higher standard deductions
lower tax bill as a result uh so now the
other thing that comes up sometimes is
should a married couple married filing
jointly or married filing separately
there's almost zero times that a married
couple married filing separately doesn't
pay more taxes married filing jointly
almost always like 98 is less taxes so
uh very very unusual if you don't run
into that so you don't want to file
separately if you're married you do want
to file head of household if you can and
qualify and you're single so for more
tax tips and software that can help you
file with confidence head on over to
ramseysolutions.com smarttax Ramsay
smart tax guides you through the online
filing process low upfront pricing no
hidden fees no tricks not going to try
to sell you debt
ramsesolutions.com smart tax so if you
use those people like TurboTax they
might try to sell you a credit card oh
they will because they're Intuit they're
owned by Quicken and they're going to
sell you rocket mortgage and credit
cards and all this other stuff which is
the whole reason they have TurboTax it's
not even to do taxes it's just to get
you in the top of their marketing funnel
so they can pedal that to you so the
dirty little trick of the business there
just to let you know how this stuff
works Ada is with us Ada is in
Indianapolis Hi Ada welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you
sure what's up glad to talk to you you
too
um I'm recently
recently
and that was quick what happened
um a heart issue oh my gosh how long
were you married honey
49 years oh my God 49.
wow
my youngest daughter says I was a baby
when we got married I really wasn't but
we were young and in college
and I've had great 49 years I'm so
excited devastating thank you
yeah it is
but I'm trying to
um I want to make sure that I'm
um living
a way that I can bless my children and
my grandchildren When I'm Gone
and that I can we are debt free that's
great I um tweeted out
that if we're going to buy a farm and we
did and we paid for it and that helped
send our girls to college
so we didn't have any debt for that they
incurred some debt because of wanting to
travel to Europe and different things
but for the most part
um so how are you today you're 100 debt
free and you have money as well
um that we have gotten and we were on
Social Security but we really didn't
have a lot of what's your what's your
income now
um my income's probably going to be
about forty nine thousand dollars how
old are you
69. and you have zeroed that house or
anything
nope I just recently had to get hearing
aids and so I'm looking at um doing that
for 18 months um interest-free until I
get my money situated around and because
some of those things don't happen right
away and you lose income and then have
to check Medicaid Medicare and make sure
they don't pay for them they probably do
no they don't okay
um okay I'm so sorry how can we help you
best
well
and tried to save for that and I I think
that if I were to be in a budget and and
looking ahead and and
um trying to find the best you know with
insurance and and trying to pay things
so that it's not you know a monthly I'd
like to be more um you need to feel in
control because everything's out of
control
right I don't blame you okay
um we would love to help you
the only question I've got is
uh I'm an old dog and I'm about your age
so uh is an old dog ready to learn some
new tricks
yes okay because I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
stretch I'm gonna stretch your learning
bone because you asked me to
okay are you ready to do that
yes okay we want to put our arms around
you and help you because
um as Christians one of our mandates to
take care of widows and orphans okay
so um and so what we're going to do is
where Jade and I are going to put you
through Financial Peace University it's
a nine-week class one nine lessons you
take them in nine weeks you'll be in a
group of people uh and we're also going
to set you up with one of our Ramsay
coaches and in that class we're not only
going to teach you budgeting but we're
going to teach you everything else you
need to do with money to where you're
going to feel competent and in control
during this worst time of your life
because you need something that is a
solid rock right now
that's true because 49 years has fallen
out from under you right now
yeah
I've been married 40 years or something
happened to Sharon honey I couldn't
breathe okay I'm with you I know I
couldn't find my way to the refrigerator
she she will testify to that by the way
but um anyway the uh
yeah so and and here's the second thing
so the first thing is you need to do
that the second thing is I do not want
you making any big
financial decisions while you can't
breathe
it's going to take a little while for
the waves to quit crashing on your
emotions to where you can breathe a
little bit it's always going to hurt
you're always going to miss him I don't
mean that but six months from now you'll
have less fog in your brain does that
make sense it makes a lot of sense
because the first month was really funky
yeah
mine's foggy right now just listening to
you and it's not even me I know Ada are
you plugged into a church home
no I would I would love for you to call
up a friend everybody's got that friend
that's always talking about their church
I would love for you to call up that
friend and say hey can I go with you
next Sunday I just want you to get
connected to people who can speak life
into you who can help help hold your
arms up during this time it sounds like
you've got a great family and and you've
got that but I would really love for you
to get connected uh just with some great
people who will love you well during
this time so was it North View or North
Valley we were in last week there in
Indiana uh North Point North Point we
were in an Indianapolis a great church
we were just up there in spoke last week
yeah so you think I remember where I was
I was trying to look for my notes I
think North Point is Atlanta I'm trying
to it's north something okay North yeah
it's right there in Indian it's a great
church to check into so the whole thing
is is that you need Community while
you're working through stuff that's
really really hard right and you're
doing that and we'll put you into the
Financial Peace University community and
help you do that and that's of no charge
and we're going to set you up with
Ramsay coach at no charge if I do all of
that will you promise me you'll do it
yes I will okay the other thing you and
don't make any big decisions until the
fog clears and the third thing is if you
need anything you call us we're right
here okay
all right you're gonna be okay honey I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry wow that's tough
stuff
Community Dave that's the well Dr John
Delaney talks about this all the time
grief Demands a witness and so being in
the presence of other people when you're
grieving and even if they don't say
anything especially if they don't say
anything so people say stupid stuff
usually in that situation but if best
thing you can do is just be silent and
hug somebody right but grief just
demands a witness I got a good friend
that was diagnosed with
later stage cancer just a few weeks ago
and I ran into her out here in the lobby
I didn't do anything except just walk up
to her and she stopped by her for
something I just walked over and gave
her a big long hug that's all that's all
because what can you say I'm not a
medical doctor I'm not a cancer right
but nothing I can do but I love her yeah
you know
ouch
well she's got
she's got to know yeah
mental peas get plugged in a little
Church she's gonna be all right
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America this is
the Ramsay show Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us Doyle is up next in
Cincinnati hi Doyle how are you
fine how are you better than we deserve
what's up sir
40 in one year from 2 900 to 4100
and I'm just wondering whether I should
keep this or just not continue with it
any longer
how much money do you have
well I had enough money to to pay the
four thousand no that wasn't what I
asked I asked how much money you have
uh well I have an income I'm retired of
about 70 well by 85 with interest on
that okay do you have any nest egg
million Nest Egg okay are you married
no I'm single okay
um so if you burn through the half a
million to take care of you in a nursing
home
just your inheritance is harmed am I
correct
correct okay the average nursing home
stay is average nursing home stays 2.4
years
okay and the average cost is eighty to a
hundred thousand dollars
per year
okay so we're talking about a quarter
million dollars is your typical burn on
this and you've got a half a million
dollars
correct that's the average averages come
from some are shorter
some are longer right
right so that's your analysis do you
want to self-insure through this or pay
fourth is it forty one hundred dollars a
year that's what you're saying right
right yeah it's going from 2 900 to 4100
and it covers you for what four or five
years
uh which unlimited 341 a day daily
benefit two percent inflation Factor
okay uh
and I've paid in about 50 000 which I
could use for you know probably a few
months coverage if I discontinue it
who's the uh who gets the half million
if you die
no no when you die yeah
uh my family who's your family kids
uh no just a brother or nephews okay
well basically you are 4100 is probably
not a bad trade for a 75 year old
for 80 000 a year 100 000 a year
probably not a bad trade mathematically
you agree
yes yeah
it's a lot and I hate that they went way
up on you but basically what you're
buying is a quarter million dollars
worth of coverage on average for four
thousand one hundred dollars a year at
75 years old the likelihood you use this
now you may stay two months and it's a
losing proposition you might die in a
car wreck and it's a losing proposition
you might stay six years and make money
on them I don't know
but I mean we don't know that's how this
stuff works right so do you you know it
all insurance is a bit of a an educated
bet
if you're if you're smart about it and
what we're betting is 4 100 against the
probability of an average of 250 000.
yeah I feel for me listening to this it
feels risky to let the coverage go and
follow the stat of the 2.5 years because
if he's in there longer and he runs out
of money
yeah he's up a creek without a paddle
yeah well and I I just but I you know I
guess if if you're gonna leave it to
your brother you might as well use it
yourself you can it's how you want to
look at it what do you want How
concerned are you about that half
million dollars surviving you yeah
that's what it comes down to that's true
um and so you know do you want to burn
through it I'm
I'm kind of thinking I'm gonna pay for
it myself and self-insure here's the
other thing
Doyle you may want to investigate as a
part of this decision either one's okay
with me but that's your trade-off is 4
100 for a probability or a possibility
of an average of a quarter million
that's your trade-off
um and you know that sounds like a good
trade when you say it that way yeah now
the other thing is this though if you
were to do uh let's say okay I'm going
to allocate I'm going to uh designate
someone to take care of my money if I'm
incapacitated and I'm going to designate
them to hire and provide me with 24-hour
a day in-home care and hire a full-time
nurse now that and you probably can do
that cheaper than a nursing home
and you might enjoy it more well maybe I
would think so you're in you're in your
own home depends I mean you know you're
by yourself too but I mean but but uh
so that's you know like in my case I'm
more than able to self-insure I'm 63. I
do not have long-term care insurance but
I've got but you can substantial net
worth and if something happens and I'm
homebound Sharon I was going to hire
somebody full-time we've already got
that arranged I'll hire somebody
full-time something happens to her uh
because we're just going to do it
because we want to be there yeah in that
case and so uh I mean you you can buy a
hospital bed you can hire a full-time
nurse an RN I mean it just it's not that
expensive it's not as expensive and make
your own food and that kind of stuff oh
yeah so that that's the that's the
provision you're not having to provide
shelter because you've already got the
shelter and that that's the issue so
that that's always an option for
especially if you're choosing to
self-insure yeah I would look into it uh
I moved here from South Florida and
South Florida is like the retirement
capital of the world and that's what
everybody did everybody would hire a
live-in nurse and have 24-hour care that
was yes that is far more popular than
going to a nursing home or going to a
facility is you have somebody move in
with you and take 24-hour care of you
you know you do need to don't don't
cheap out don't go eight hour care for
24 hours well yeah make sure you're
taken care of right don't cheap because
you're you're saving money anyway so
don't cheap out yeah yeah uh and you got
this great income from the pensions of
85 000 a year so he's got some options
he's going to be real tempted to
self-insure
um partly because I'm kind of with you
Doyle it pisses me off they went up that
much
but it probably is based in math I mean
it's probably based on 75 year old
higher probability right that's true
that's true that's how they're getting
there Chris is in Wilmington North
Carolina hi Chris welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey how you doing Dave better than we
deserve what's up
hey so I'm a rethink graduate of college
um and now I just got a full-time job
and I'm working good great um and I'm
really look looking forward to stopping
to have to pay uh rental income or pay
rent
um because you know it's just money down
the drain uh never getting back uh so
I'm really looking for a plan or
something to do uh to set myself up so I
can hopefully get out of the situation
in the near future new future as in five
years
um to
um be able to buy a home do you have a
job
yes I do have a full-time job
um what are you earning during the week
uh 55k okay is this your long is this
what you want to be doing long term or
is just kind of a transitional deal yeah
so this is this is my career job
um it's and my field I went to school
for
um and then I also have
um part-time 1099 income that I do okay
on the weekends uh from March to
November um the baseball empire
um okay pretty steady and is that on top
of the 55k or is that included correct
no that's uh on top
20K doing that again any debt I have
student learned that student loans
um about 20K your first goals roll up
your sleeves and get rid of that as fast
as you possibly can
and then you build an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses by the
way I want that done by Christmas
I want you debt free by Christmas you're
55 you're single you've got nothing to
do with that money but party or get out
of debt so get out of debt yes so all
you got that's your two choices okay get
out of debt that's your only job get rid
of Sallie Mae evict the old woman she's
ugly you don't want her in a spare
bedroom and if you don't do it if you
have card debt because I'm just you
didn't say it but if you have a car debt
pay that off too because that counts 100
debt free then build your emergency fund
a three to six months of expenses then
save you a good down payment as 20 is
best because you avoid PMI private
mortgage insurance when you put 20 down
on a conventional loan that's your best
bet you can do all of that by the time
you're 25 in your situation everything
you're wanting to do there is very very
possible but do it in that order and
that's the fastest way this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Brandon's in
Louisville Kentucky hey Brandon what's
up
hey thanks for taking my call today sure
how can we help
so I have a question about what I should
where I should be focusing my money so I
went through majority of your stats I am
debt free with everything besides my
house I do the 15 into my retirement to
my 401k I have a relatively new son
that's six months old so I started the
529 and started investing in that
but thank you my question is so I've I
bought a house
um a couple years ago two three years
ago bought a pretty good time my
mortgage that I have left on it is about
250 000 it's worth around 300 to 315 000
um but I've put about fifty thousand
dollars in individual stocks and then I
have an additional a hundred and three
thousand roughly in just savings on the
side and my question is should I be
taking that money out of the individual
stocks and trying to beat that mortgage
down as much as possible or how should I
be investing this money what should be
focusing on on a Direction with this
money you seem you seem like you're
awfully familiar with what we do uh-huh
until that last part
relatively new to listen to you guys
it's probably been a few months I've not
been listening to you guys but but you
know the baby steps but yeah like I said
I love the I love the method you guys
you try to make it as simple as possible
but I feel like I'm at the point where
like I'm still relatively young but I'm
like I want to get ahead as fast as
possible you do look I'm not gonna stay
in this home forever but I'm probably
going to move out of it in a couple
years so I'm like does it make sense no
beat down my mortgage here let me help
you let me help you what you're what
you've been doing which is the baby
steps has been working for you so let's
keep on doing that so the way we would
teach it is you're already investing in
the 529 that's great you've got all this
extra money the 50k in single stocks
103k is that above and beyond your three
to six months I'm assuming
yeah that is everything uh yeah a
savings portion so what we would do next
is put you know we're paying off the
mortgage so you've got this extra money
if if it were me I would cancel I would
cash out the 50k and single stocks
there's going to be some tap tax
implication there so you've got to be
prepared for that but I would do that
because you've got 250 left on this
mortgage you could pay off 150
by the end of the month what's your
household income
um so I make around 250 000. and you're
how old
uh 26. okay way to go you're doing
really good Brandon she's so good what
we have discovered in studying
millionaires
not not someone's theory on Tic Tac but
real millionaires okay what we've
discovered in studying 10 000 of them is
the shortest distance between where you
are and the first one to five million
dollars is two things
loading your 401ks at 15 of your income
going in like you're doing and becoming
100 debt free using what used to be
payments then to build wealth with by
steadily investing
okay the number of millionaires that we
interviewed we interviewed 10 000 of
them that said I ran up a bunch of
profit in single stocks and and used
that to pay off my house and that caused
me to be rich was almost nothing almost
none of them there was a few but there's
percentage-wise it would have been well
less than five percent of them 95
percent of them followed the plan of not
just our plan but just the idea the
common sense idea of my most powerful
wealth building tool is this wonderful
income you have because you're obviously
bright you're 26 years old you make 250
000 dumb people don't do that so we know
you're bright okay and so uh that that
you know that that is your secret sauce
not the stocks not leveraging your house
right you are the secret sauce in the
equation so if I'm you uh I put a
hundred and fifty thousand minus an
emergency fund if you set aside 20 for
your emergency fund so 100 130 000 on
your two hundred fifty thousand dollar
loan and you have a two hundred fifty
thousand dollar income with no other
payment so I think I understood that
that's right and that means I'm gonna
knock off you're going to be debt free
when you're 28 house and everything and
then you've got 250
000 freaking dollars to invest steadily
You're Gonna Be A Millionaire when
you're 35 if you do what we tell you to
do
I am paying uh PMI on my mind I'm mad at
you you're brilliant you've done a great
job
fine tuning your excellent plan you
pulled up here in an Indy car all we're
doing is tuning it up
okay well I just you know how it is you
like to look at the bank you like to see
the the savings I'm really good about
stockpiling money let me tell you what
let me tell you I don't know how it is
what I know how it is is when you pay
off your house and you walk through the
backyard without any shoes on the grass
feels different
it probably does it does I promise you
so hey here's the thing if I'm wrong and
to in a year and a half from now you're
100 debt free and you hate it you can go
get you a mortgage
that's a great way to look at it all
right hey man pay off your house as fast
as you possibly can that's your next
step and and don't get too caught up in
the stocks yeah I'll say that too yeah
single stocks or single stocks are
pretty much a Gamble pretty much a
gamble I don't buy single stocks we
recommend if you're going to do single
stocks just because you can't stand it
for whatever reason not to have more
than 10 of your net worth in single
stocks I buy mutual funds that's all I
do and and real estate that I pay cash
yeah that's all I do I built 100 of my
wealth doing that that's all I've done
it's very simple and you know he made a
good point the thing you have to watch
against and Brandon he didn't get there
but he walked up on the edge of it I
heard him
he's not really there because he's very
smart yeah he is obviously a smart young
man okay when I was his age
I would have been more than smart I
would have been arrogant okay yes that
would have been the category I would
have been in so here's what I find he
said you guys what you teach is so
simple and there's a lot of compliment
in that but there was also a but I know
better because I'm smarter than simple
yeah he wanted there to be more be
smarter than simple if you get smarter
than simple that's when you get your toe
cut off in the lawnmower just don't get
don't get smarter than simple it's a bad
idea because let me just tell you some
of the most profound life-changing
things you will learn in this life are
very easy to understand and very hard to
do let me give you one yes love your
neighbor
oh but he's a jerk yeah I know what to
do
it oh my gosh simple design I mean I got
a lot of the guys on Tic Tac and Twitter
oh man oh
I know what to do I just can't do it
it's simple it is simple but not easy
very simple some of the things that most
profound things are simple but not easy
Brittany's with us Britney's in Oklahoma
City Brittany we're short on time go
fast
okay
um I am currently doing the baby steps I
started
fertilized um end up using it what um
on moving out of my apartment to another
apartment why
um my lease was up on my apartment did
you go down and ramp
I did not I went up there I say I can't
help you if you keep doing this stuff
I know
the part of the place that I was living
I could not it was like infested
[Laughter]
okay you got to quit moving the wrong
direction kid yeah we gotta look we're
trying to lower the expensives raise the
income you got to get on those baby
steps hurry up and get that thousand
dollars re-saved and then you're gonna
start through going through your debt
snowball and watch these moves don't be
yeah that was impulsive as crap and you
know it that's why I'm picking at you
because we love you and we don't want
you to do that anymore don't be so
dadgum impulsive now if you got a nasty
butt thing and there's roaches running
around you got to make a move that's one
thing okay I get that but on the you
know but you really need to just stop
and slow down he who is impulsive exalts
Folly do not be impulsive I've been
impulsive most of my life and every time
I'm impulsive right after that I get
broke hahaha
that's true slow down slow down make
slow calm wise decisions be the tortoise
not the hair now work your baby steps
again and start fresh but if you undo
them every time you get started I can't
help you it's not going to help you we
don't have a baby step for those that
start over all the time you know it
doesn't work that way this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Leo in Fresno California
starts us off hi Leo how are you
hi Dave um and Jade how are you doing
good how can we help
um so for
so much for taking a call just to give
you a little bit of background I
um I'm I'm encountering a situation
where I don't know what to do or how to
detach from it
um I've been a full provider for a
really long time and I was a single mom
for a very long time and
um I've been in the banking industry for
more than 60 years so it's basically all
I know I'm new to the Dave and Ramsey
um podcast and so my question is their
values and morals no longer align with
what I feel
um brings fulfillment to my life so
um because this is all I know
um I don't know how to detach or let go
or how to even navigate this this new
season of my life so
I was hoping I could get some
orientation in a sense so what's an
example of can you give me an example of
how it doesn't line up I think I know
what you mean but just for clarity's
sake so so Jade
um
you know you're you're in a self-like
environment where
um you basically
uh
encourage and you know incentivize
people to get in debt right okay okay
and
and I no longer find right that to be
a part of who I want to be anymore so
have you started looking for other
opportunities other job opportunities
that are not uh requiring you to do debt
sales
um I have however I have not been very
successful I think I've had one or two
interviews um
you know within Wells Health Fargo is
what I call it
um and so
um
I I haven't had any luck well I think
you just got to keep going out there I
think you got to get clear about what
what it is that you want to do from this
point on because like you said that
industry was all that you knew so you're
finding now that your values don't align
with that so now it's time to start
painting the picture of what your values
do align with and what it is that you
want to do long term and start looking
for those opportunities and it probably
is going to take you applying for more
than just one or two jobs you're
probably gonna have to really put
yourself out there you know and and keep
throwing your net out completely Leo how
old are you
I am 35 and what do you make
around 80 a year my husband makes around
140. okay
um can you live on 140
um
yeah we can all right I mean for six
months
yeah that's what he actually suggests
yeah um I'm not saying you had to I'm
just saying if you accept that
emotionally and swallow that it gives
you a lot of peace
because now you're just staying in the
bank until you find something uh and you
don't feel as trapped
you're not trying I feel trapped right
you're not you're not trapped your
husband's right you could quit today and
take six months to wander around doing
something you'll find something to do
okay what do you do what do you actually
do at the bank what is your title
that's perfect so that sets you up those
are transferable skills to do business
relationships in other businesses
other businesses that want to interact
in what we call B2B business to business
transactions would find your skill set
of having formerly worked at the bank
very valuable
but you're not any more trapped than you
the only reason you're traps you feel
like you are you've got very
transferable skills your husband makes
enough money for y'all to live on until
you make the move
so you're not trapped but I wouldn't
quit I would just go on a very uh let's
pretend that if you don't get a job in
four months that you will get a terminal
illness let's use that kind of
motivation
okay okay just go in other words what
would you do if you said if I don't have
a new job in four months I'm gonna die
well then you would go get a new job you
would you wouldn't talk to three people
you talk to 300 right because how how
much time up until this point Leo how
much time have you put into your job sir
let's just talk to three people I mean
yeah
yeah you're just gonna have to do more
you're playing with it and you're
rehearsing this as you drive to work mad
at yourself stop feeling stuck and
you're rehearsing it over and over and
over in your head I want you to rehearse
it in front of human beings and get a
new job
so I'm going to send you Ken Coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose I'm going
to send you his uh assessment
which is his career assessment take that
takes 27 minutes to take it I'm going to
give it all to you for free and I'm
going to give you his other number one
bestseller proximity principle which
will help you land the job if I give you
all of that will you read those two
books and go interview to 22 people in
the next three days
I'm kidding in the next 30 days in the
next 30 days okay well you do it
immediately with some urgency
I I will I want some Swagger girl yeah I
want you Swagger
I want to see you strut up that well
sidewalk not walk up with your head down
going I'm not worthy mm-hmm
you make 80 grand a year you're not done
dumb people don't make 80 grand
well maybe a few I'm not sure I was
gonna say Dave maybe just a few oh my
gosh but I'm serious I mean you have a
lot you're giving yourself a credit of a
two out of 100 and I'm giving you a
credit for 102 out of 100. yeah I think
she was thinking she could just kind of
like tap her are toe in the water and
maybe something magical would happen but
you've gotta you can't find Godmother's
not coming you're the secret sauce kiddo
get out there get after it yeah get
after it that's how you do it hang on
we're gonna give you those two books and
that career assessment and help you get
started on this we want you to be able
to win hey if you are a new listener and
you want to dive deeper into the Ramsey
Baby Steps go to ramsesolutions.com
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the next best step
for your financial journey and we'll
figure out where you are in the baby
steps tell you what to do next we're
going to walk you through oh by the way
it's 100 free
did I mention it's free
can't beat the price when it's free so
go to ramseysolutions.com click on get
started take a quick little assessment
we'll land you where you land the baby
steps this is all new lingo to you
you've got all these FPU got debt
snowballs we've got baby step fours we
got all this lingo if you're brand new
you're trying to figure out what are you
talking about
so yeah click get started at
ramseysolutions.com and uh we'll walk
you through that free service to help
you kind of get plugged into the family
here you can jump rope with us you just
got to get in the Cadence right we'll
show you how to do it you can do it you
can do it join us right here I know it's
fast but it works and we'll help you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome back to the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Dave Ramsey today's
question of the day comes from Michael
in Nebraska
this he says does it you don't have to
turn on your mic
he says this does it ever make sense to
pull from retirement to pay the house
off I'm curious if it would be
acceptable to take out fifty thousand
dollars out of our Roth tsp and pay off
our mortgage my wife and I are debt free
except our mortgage we have 534 000 in
our tsp of which 150 000 is my Roth tsp
I'm 61 and work my wife is 55 and
doesn't work outside the home with my
military retirement VA disability and
federal salary we bring and make around
140k gross a year
we plan on working another three years
or so our mortgage balance is about a
hundred thousand if we stay the course
we will pay it off in five years if we
take the money out of our Roth tsp we
could pay it off in two years
I wouldn't do it
I don't I don't understand why they
wouldn't just stay the course
um
well once you're in retirement if your
nest egg is big enough that you can make
it without I what I don't understand on
this is why we're taking out why he's
not just paying it off
would you well maybe the tax
implications no there's no tax no
because it's all Roth It's all Roth and
so I mean you got a hundred thousand
hundred fifty thousand in the Roth and
if you want to pay off a hundred
thousand dollar mortgage why are we just
cutting it in half are we only putting
50 000 on it doesn't make sense either I
mean either do it or don't paint or get
off the ladder okay so
um if you pay it off you've got four
hundred and fifty thousand
and during the five years you would have
paid it off you can build up some more
retirement in a Roth and build it back
that's true
um and you got 450 000 left and you've
got VA disability federal salary
military VA disability and military
retirement so
um would I take a hundred thousand out
of 500 000 and or 534 000 and pay it off
at 61 years old
that's right on the bubble and here's
why it's right on the bubble okay uh
I if it was 200 000 and you only had a
hundred thousand left I'd say definitely
no okay definitely if it was a million
and you had nine hundred thousand I'd
say yes definitely yes okay so see how
I'm right on the bubble I'm like you
know it's like it leaves a good chunk
but it's not like so if you did this
uh-huh and I probably would I'd probably
just pay the whole thing off I would not
pay off fifty thousand and then you just
take the whole hundred thousand I'd
probably do that but the only way you do
that
is you pinky swear spit shake you and
your wife look at each other and go we
ain't doing nothing until we put that
hundred thousand back but why wouldn't
they okay I'm playing Devil's Advocate
that's good why wouldn't they because
I'm looking at at the opposite way I'm
like you're making 140k a year why can't
you live on if you really care like that
why can't you live on nothing and get
this thing paid off in two years in two
years I'm with you so that that was kind
of my thought especially if you do that
you can put it back in two years too
that's true so there's really there's
not a right answer here the bottom line
is both of those answers involve
something he's not putting on here yeah
that's right and both of them involve
intensity at way cranked up from where
Michael is right now because he's trying
to trying to play with this 50 000 out
of a hundred why are you doing 50.
that's just
you just kind of yeah come on come on
get it whatever it is you're gonna do go
all in and pay the whole thing off and
then bust it and put it back or just
bust it and pay it off now at 61 busting
it wasn't in this equation at 61 another
question does he need to bust it at all
or can he just go we're just gonna pay
off our home keep going keep trucking
along keep investing our 15 keep like
can he do that yeah he could do that
does he have to be intense at this point
but your point is
um either way the thing we're both
feeling in this that we're not that it
took a second to get to the surfaces
it's all lukewarm yeah okay get get
really really hot or really really cold
here and get it yeah whatever it is
you're gonna do and so yeah if I woke up
in his shoes which one would I do
I'm probably going to pay it off and I'm
gonna put turn on the heat and put 100
000 back in the bank in two years all
right uh but you're going to pay it off
in two years I'm gonna pay it off using
neither one of these answers are in the
dumb column that's right sure if if it
has that intensity that we were talking
about now if he pulls out that hundred
thousand and he's just you know
Meandering along yeah that that's not
okay yeah that's not gonna work Janice
is in St Louis hi Janice how are you
hi I'm well thank you I am a new
listener I found you on TBN and I've
really been enjoying your show well
thank you
you know my mother's home since she went
to heaven in early 2020 and the renter's
going to be moving out this spring and
I'm trying to decide if I want to move
in or if I want to sell the home
um I have been told that
um if I even if I decide I want to sell
it that I should probably move in for
two years and because that's a way to
recapture
that appreciation that's been claimed on
my tax returns for the last three years
so I wanted to know one is that correct
yes two if it is is that a good idea
that would be correct
um because what will happen is if you
sell your personal residence you can
make a gain of up to 250 000 as a single
person and your personal residence means
you had to live there for two years okay
okay and that gain would include the
recaptured depreciation because you're
converting it from a rental property to
a to a personal residence after it has
not been a rental property for very long
now if it had been a rental property for
five years you would not have this
option
so if you're going to do this you've got
to do it now okay okay now
mathematically that is going to work and
it's not a bad idea at all if you if you
want to do that here's the thing
okay what's the house worth
um I think that Zillow has it it's
something like it's a wide range but I
think they've put it at 3 15. what do
you think it's worth
I think it's probably worth more than
that probably 400 okay and so what was
your depression how much depreciation
did you take in that one year
oh gosh I don't know my my tax preparer
knows all that I I'm sure they wouldn't
be doing this standard schedule yeah it
wasn't that much okay
um and so the the taxes on this if you
sell it today are not gonna be much
because here's what happens your basis
in Inherited property that the tax is
calculated on is what it was worth at
the time she passed
minus whatever depreciation you've taken
that's all you're going to pay taxes on
is anything over that figure
and it's not going to be substantial so
if you hate I don't hate it's not the
right word but if I really don't want to
live there but I'm holding my nose just
because my tax thing sounds right oh
it's a nice house don't do it but if
it's like it might be kind of a cool
adventure and I'd probably save 10 grand
or something then that's okay but it's
not a hundred thousand dollar swing in
this discussion it's a five or a ten
thousand dollar swing in this discussion
okay okay
well
if I don't
will it after it's been a rental it am I
am I am I exposed to capital gains yes
yes and the capital gains will be
calculated this way the value at the
time of your mother's death is your
basis that's as if you paid that number
for it
okay okay minus any depreciation you
take
and so let's say it's 400 000 value at
the time she passed then you take uh
thirty thousand dollars worth of
depreciation now your basis your
adjusted basis is 370. you follow me you
sell it later for 570.
many years from now okay
okay that's a two hundred thousand
dollar gain over that 370.
you see I did that but your gain is not
the whole 570 when you sell it it's over
whatever your original value was minus
whatever depreciation you take
okay and each time each time your basis
is lowered each year by the depreciation
you take on your taxes that's called
your adjusted basis because you're
adjusting the cost downward by the
amount you're writing off
is that logical it sounded pretty soupy
to me when I said it
is a capital gains tax um is it more
than than personal oh no it's a lot less
fifteen percent fifteen percent
15 yeah and your and your personal is
probably probably more than that
so that's what I'm saying even if you
sold it today what little gyration
you've done with this depreciation and
the recapture and all that over what it
was worth when she passed it's not going
to be much money five or ten thousand
bucks Max
and uh uh so you hadn't had time to mess
it up too much in terms of the
calculation for taxes very interesting
call thank you Janice thanks for being a
new viewer on TBN for those of you don't
know it's one of the places you can now
watch the show every afternoon this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Nicholas and Samantha are
with us hey guys how are you fantastic
welcome where do y'all live Upstate New
York Albany just West Albany called
skahari a bit of a halt in Nashville
welcome good to have you how much debt
have you paid off 235
000. how long did that take 46 months
good for you and your range of income
during that five eight four years I'm
sorry we started out around 65 and we
ended up about 150 last year what do you
all do for a living I'm a physical
therapist that works with children
very good I work in maintenance at a
power plant excellent excellent so what
kind of debt was your 235 000. 14 000
was a car and the rest was student loans
wow Sally May set up shop yeah
absolutely wow wow a physical therapy
degree right there's a lot of it I was
gonna ask that was about 180 of it was
the physical therapy degree yeah wow wow
so what happened 46 months ago that made
you guys go all right that's like what
was that I've had it moment because
everybody's got one that made you just
throw your hands up and say we got to do
this I think when you're young and you
first get married you don't you don't
really think about
you have the future like that and then
um I started listening to the podcast
shortly after we got married how did you
find out about the podcast in Albany
um I
I was honestly just looking for a
podcast and you guys come up as
recommended for uh personal growth
business stuff like that so I had heard
of Dave Ramsey before but the podcast
and when I started listening was really
when I got started
um and I will say uh I I definitely
presented it to my wife the wrong way
so for all of you husbands and spouses
out there listening uh I she was in a
conference in uh Rhode Island so she was
away for a couple days and I called her
and said that I was gonna change
everything your exact words where I'm
gonna rock your world which tears ensued
in a good way
what happened after you regained
Consciousness
we had many many talks
um most of them starting with tears and
then as I really started to understand
the debt and how it was going to impact
Our Lives long term I I was like okay I
you know I'll give it a shot let's let's
do Financial Peace and um now we really
both got us on the same page with going
through Financial Peace University
together okay you presented it much
better than I did
for sure for sure well if you say I'm
gonna rock your world through the
television and it's not your husband you
can get away with a lot
so so good so what was the hardest part
along this journey you do FPU you start
learning the principles what was kind of
the first what was the first thing that
you guys kind of rallied around and said
all right we need to do this
as the free spirit the budget
um him he wrote it all out and then he's
like you need to be involved and I was
like uh uh you just do it so getting on
the same page with all of that for sure
forcing each other to sit down and talk
about what we're gonna spend so he went
from I'm gonna rock your world to your
vote counts so much you have to do this
yes that's a good move we both drew a
lot yeah yeah okay it's a good move good
move and then you finally did sit down
and say okay I'm gonna make my vote
count I'm gonna hold my nose and look
eat my broccoli and look at this yes
which we needed because I'm definitely
the spender so I needed her and I'm the
saver so I I didn't want to spend
anything once I realized hey we need to
pay this off I don't want to spend a
thing oh wow okay okay so I'm definitely
the nerd spender and she's more of the
free spirit but the saver so we needed
her input very good very very cool for
you guys I'm so proud of y'all well done
well done you had a good FPU class that
cheered you on I hope yes uh at first I
would say there was not a lot of uh
support it was kind of a lot of that's
good for you I'm happy for you guys from
our families and then I mean this
journey was almost four years long so we
had a lot of cheerleaders that grew into
just
the best cheerleaders yeah our parents
were actually both uh scared of what we
were doing they both thought we were
ending ending all the fun that would
ever happen in our lives but now they're
both both families are so proud and
jumping on that train well isn't it
funny how that happens you start and
everybody's got all the questions but
then when you finish they want to know
how you did it right exactly amen new
questions yeah
very very well done well we're so proud
of you excellent excellent work these
are really good numbers you guys did
lean into it it's obvious on the numbers
this was not an easy task for you was it
absolutely not we I mean even in New
York we probably lived on about 30 000 a
year for those four years thankfully we
had affordable rent and we had um uh
family that was willing to help us out
how old are you now 27. and you got the
rest of your lives yes how does it feel
to be free oh so good yes we can
actually we can go on trips come see you
guys we're gonna go to Florida in a
couple months and then start saving a
down payment for a house if you're ever
going back in debt absolutely no
love it love it love it hey we got the
live and give bundle for you that's the
number one best seller The Total Money
Makeover and the number one bestseller
the baby steps millionaires books uh
read them give them away whatever you
want to do same thing with you been
through financial position we're going
to give you another one-year membership
to gift to somebody might even be one of
those family members that you converted
and help them get on their way that'll
be great so however you want to bless
someone with it it's for the live you
live and give bundle so very very good
stuff Nicholas and Samantha Albany New
York
now let's hear a debt-free scream three
three two one
free yeah
[Applause]
ah way to go you guys that's fabulous
Andrea is with us in New York City hey
Andrea what's up
hi Dave hi Jade what's going on
oh I'm so excited well we're happy to
have you here how can we help thank you
let me get to the point okay so uh my
husband and I were currently on baby
step number three forecasted to complete
it by May
um our take home is 5 000 a month uh my
husband brings home 36 I bring him bring
home 14. okay
um I am I'm I am 42 years old my
husband's 46 we have a 12 year old and a
10 year old we currently have 15K in
retirement from an old 401k that we
rolled over to a Roth IRA so the
question is do we immediately start
maybe step four or do we start baby step
3B once we're completed with baby step
three for a down payment on a house we
currently rent rent my parents um have a
two-family house we live on the second
floor but of course our dream is to own
our own our own homes but the Ramsey way
because we do want peace in our in our
lives but I just see it so far from our
future and that kind of this motivates
me well you know I think take it one
baby step at a time you're gonna finish
baby step three in May you said and then
from then from then on start saving 3B
if you want to own a house the only way
to get there is to start so if you get
so overwhelmed that you kind of have
that we call it paralysis analysis and
you're thinking about all the numbers
and you're wondering how it's going to
be possible you'll never make it so
you've just got to actually start
putting aside the money and as you're
putting aside the money start start
looking in the area we have a really
cool calculator online that says how
much home can I afford and start
plugging your numbers in there and
finding out how much it's going to take
for the homes in your your area what
that down payment needs to look like and
start working towards it and here's the
thing you guys worked to pay off the
debt you worked to build up your three
to six months if you want to know what
you can do you can work to build up your
down payment
and and you've done it before so you can
do it again and yes it's going to take a
little bit of time but like you said you
want to work through the steps because
it's worth it for you to have that peace
right
yeah Andre how much debt have y'all paid
off
let me tell you when you started the 55
it seemed insurmountable
yes to Jade's point then you you plowed
through it you did it so if you can pay
it off 55 I'll bet you can save 55.
okay now
you drove right past that it's the same
stinking math it's the same math but
yeah if you could pay off 55
and you know now you don't have any
payments except your house except your
rent and if you can pay off 55 you can
save 55. and you'll do it even faster
it's doable yeah it should go faster
yeah it will go faster so now you're
getting good at it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America guys how many of you are
thinking about buying a house
truly not a bad time to buy at all
things have slowed down out there have
you noticed
and that means there's not 73 people
putting in an offer every 26 minutes
and in other words you're not like
you're buying a house two years ago it's
like being in an auction oh my gosh it's
like being an animal you don't have to
go to an auction anymore now you just
like walk up and then you kind of make
an offer and then they maybe make a
counter offer and then maybe you counter
that and by the way if you're selling a
house it's a great time to sell a house
because there's actually still a
shortage of housing there are still more
buyers looking than there are houses for
sale
uh yeah interest rates are up and house
prices are up but there's still more
buyers looking than there are houses for
sale so if you're selling a house don't
expect 73 offers in 26 minutes you're
going to instead you're going to have a
a normal
yeah I've been selling real estate since
1978 and my license okay that long I
haven't been selling it but I've been
around buying and been in the real
estate business my whole life
and I've never seen a time except that
one little period of time there where uh
you didn't put a house on the market you
put a house on the market getting full
price a hundred percent was unheard of
up until that short period of time
getting multiple offers was unheard of
except during that short period of time
and a house typically took 30 to 120
days to sell except during that short
period of time but we went through a
period of time where uh the world was
turned upside down the world was so
crazy that used cars went up and
unbelievable this is like I mean the
world's upside down like you're living
in Australia it's upside down I mean
it's just crazy I mean wow but all of
that's kind of smoothed out now now
listen if you need to borrow your Best
Bets actually a 15-year fixed rate and
you get on track you pay the house off
immediately you don't have to be
intimidated you don't want the payment
to be more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on that we have a free
mortgage calculator on our website give
you an idea what your payment would look
like and we're not trying to sell you a
mortgage because we're not the mortgage
business go figure ramseysolutions.com
click free tools there's a ton of tools
there one of them is the free mortgage
calculator free tools all kinds of
calculation stuff you want to do you
want to learn about your money you want
to get control of it you want to tell it
what to do instead of wonder where it
went all that kind of stuff
ramsesolutions.com and click on free
tools it will get you there that's what
we used Jade warshaw Ramsey
personalities my co-host today Freddy is
in New York City hi Freddy how are you
hey Dave what's going on
walking our way through it brother
what's up all right what's up I I have
an annuity that I've owned
for 10 years
that's when I don't see it going
anywhere I feel like I do better
somewhere else you're right that's 58 I
have 58 000 in car payments the
annuities worth 68 60 800. should I just
lick my wounds and pay off my cause but
then I'm debt free I'm baby stuff seven
debt free
what's the rest of your net worth
I'm worth
the time in funds and about a million
dollars in real estate and you're 65.
how old are you no I'm 57. oh okay close
enough yeah all right I know you're
right in there somewhere all right yeah
yeah I I could kind of smell it on you
by the way it's a good it's a good smell
like a cologne okay it's not yeah so
yeah you're doing good in other words in
other words because I because some
people call up with 58 000 with a car
debt and I'm and I might give them a
talking to about it but I think you can
afford it so yeah cash the annuity out
pay off your cars you're right on track
Freddie you got a couple million dollar
net worth you're not doing dumb stuff
way to go I'm proud of you all right pay
it off be done be dead free and then
start investing my rotary erase more
just dump it all into my routes yeah you
got it baby do you have paid paid for
homes Keep It Rock yeah you should baby
step seven everything there you go yeah
on three properties I own you know I
just want to get done I just want to be
done I love that and and and don't don't
play math games next time you get ready
to buy a car just buy it with money
Cold Hard Cash yeah you played math
games that's how you did that because
you're trying to figure out some way to
beat the system and with a stupid car
you lose
every time I always find that to be
weird Dave you always lose on a car you
got 628
000 in real estate and retirement
millions millions of dollars but you're
still getting a car note I don't
understand that went in there and
negotiated and I got to tell you that
the car dealers they look at you like
you got one eye in the center of your
head when you write them a check they do
not know what to do with that they
Babble and walk around in circles
they'll try to tell you they can't take
the check yeah when we try when we try
to buy our first car in cash I remember
we had the check right there and they
gave us such a run around Dave I mean
they they made up excuses why this
wasn't gonna work I got a weird one
happened the other day that was the
opposite of course I've been dealing
with this dealership for quite a while I
just bought the brand new Raptor right
the the big one and um the big one the
white 700 horsepower it's so freaking
sweet but the uh um I wrote them a chat
a literal check and we usually wire
money what is this we wire money we have
cars and I had no they asked me to I
said I'll wire you the money and they
said well just just send a checkout oh
of course they know me I've been doing
business with me for a while so they
know the check's probably okay but but
uh just send us a check they'd rather
have that than a wire I had not run into
that because I almost always wire money
yeah they're buying a car these days
well checks are from like you would say
when dinosaurs roam the earth I know we
had to print one off and and card it up
there you know it was fine I didn't mind
it it was just felt different I don't
know what because the wire should be
faster it should be but I whatever maybe
they just maybe they wanted to hold a
check from Dave Ramsey in their hand I
don't think so I think it's something I
didn't understand oh well it's all good
Lee is with us Lee is in uh Lexington
Kentucky hi Lee how are you
hello Mr Ramsey I'm doing well good how
can we help
I have a stock that I'm considering
selling to pay off my mortgage good I'm
just not sure how much to set aside for
the capital gains taxes do you know what
you paid for it
what's it worth today what's it worth
today 28
000. 28 000. okay so somewhere around
twenty six thousand dollars is the gain
does that make sense the difference in
what you saw it for versus what you paid
for it that much is taxable at 15
percent
so your taxes are going to be somewhere
between four and five thousand dollars
okay you see how I did that yes yes I
did yeah and so if you're off by a
thousand dollars it's not good you're
gonna be okay but you need to set aside
out of this money four or five five
thousand aside and then when you do your
taxes you can find out exactly what the
gain was but um you need to go back to
um or go to either your current broker
or whoever you were when you purchased
it and see if they can give you the
actual purchase price because you do
have to verify that to create the
calculation you want the exact number
but it's somewhere between a thousand
twenty five hundred it's worth somewhere
around twenty six thousand
um and
um our 28 000 and we're gonna take two
thousand off of that so that's going to
be your gain
that's how it works and it's only 15 so
that's 1500 per 10 000 of gains so if
you've got a thirty thousand dollar gain
that'd be forty five hundred
so we know it's 4 500 or less in this
case it's probably probably said four
thousand dollars aside and you'll be
just fine yeah that's going to be real
close um again I'm doing big numbers
here I'm not doing nitzi to the penny
calculations but I'm not going to be I'm
going to be within three or four hundred
dollars of where you end up on this
assuming the numbers you gave me are
correct that is so that that's how it
works so the good news about capital
gains is you don't pay taxes on it until
you sell it and when you do sell it it's
at that reduced rate
very good so good good stuff and you
know that works with um anything that
you hold and goes up in value real
estate
I hold do you pay no taxes on the
increase in value until you sell it uh
it's called a realized game but not a
recognized gain you realize it when it
went up in value you recognize it for
tax purposes when you sell it
and so you have to kind of admit that it
happened so to speak
um and the same thing's true if you buy
a low turnover mutual fund like if
you're a baby step seven you're
completely debt free and you're doing
other investing they don't sell the
stocks inside the mutual fund very often
it grows
in gains primarily and there's very
little to no taxes on it until you sell
a low turnover mutual fund so uh look
for a turnover ratio that's like down
around five percent or something like
that so that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen good stuff good question Lee
well done well done well done get that
mortgage paid off I love your plan this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Greg's in
Spokane hi Craig how are you
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up yeah excellent
well I um I've been wanting to give you
a call for a while because I think I I
don't know I asked my accountant she had
one for him of answering it but I'm
wondering if I should
um pay off my house and it's just under
160 000.
so do you have any other debt
I have no other debt and do you have an
emergency fund saved up three to six
months of expenses
I have
um about 450
000. saved up
that saved up well you have a hundred
and sixty thousand dollar mortgage
correct okay
all right how did you save up all this I
can can you tell me more about this 450k
you have saved I'm just interested
yeah well well right yeah well okay so
um I guess I can't necessarily say that
I have all of that that because because
part of it is is just you know it's
coming through the through the business
and and that sort of thing
um about a year and a half ago
um
um I was able to pay off all of my other
debt which was about a hundred hundred
thousand dollars
um and then get a to get a 401k
um started for me and my employees
um and uh and so so do you have 450 000
in cash or not
well I have I have 450 000 in the bank
okay yes and it's your money
yes okay it's your money no caveat on
that I mean if you own the business and
some of it's in the business account
it's still your money right
right I'm not sure we want to take it
all out but we're not only talking about
160 000 out of 450. right why would you
not pay off your mortgage
well so when I asked my accountant that
just recently and she was like well
you'd probably make more if you you know
put it into some kind of high yield
something that's you're going to make
more interest than you would by Saving
because my interest rate is 2.5 on that
this is really bad advice
um the way we would teach it is the way
we would teach it is through the baby
steps and you've done them you've got
you've done baby step one two and three
I wanted to check and make sure you're
doing the 15 into retirement it sounds
like you are and then from there if you
have kids you're saving for your kids
college you're putting away in a 529 or
an Esa and so yeah now you're to baby
step six you've got the money assuming
that this is you know bottom line money
everybody's payroll is paid this is just
your retained earnings or whatever
you've got this money here yeah pay off
your debt you know pay off the whatever
you owe on the mortgage and then if you
have money left over above and beyond
that that you want to continue to invest
or pay cash for Real Estate then yeah
the world is your oyster yeah you take
your old house payment and use it to get
rich with yeah
not the other way around
if you were to say you know pay off the
house my next question was going to be
what is the best thing to do with you
know that that mortgage payment that
I've been yeah I would get I would get
in touch with your broker if you don't
have one to jump online at Ramsey
Solutions and find a smart investor Pro
we call them they follow the stuff that
we teach and their uh mutual fund
Brokers they'll help you get up a mutual
fund account and I would set up how much
is your house payment
1700 yeah I just set up two thousand
dollars a month automatic draft out of
your checking account I did that years
ago when I paid off my house and here's
what's weird
I just never thought about it again
two thousand dollars a month I used to
pay a house payment now I pay myself and
you know I I looked up and it was a
million dollars
it went I mean it was just like it felt
like 20 seconds but it wasn't it was
longer than that but how fast two
thousand dollars a month becomes serious
money is will blow your mind I mean a
decade it's going to be I don't know
exactly what the number is but it's
going to be there so fast that that's
where you want to go so two thoughts for
you to chew on that indicate that your
accountant is wrong okay number one uh
thought
we did the largest study of millionaires
that's ever been done in North America
airtight research
the typical way that a person achieves a
net worth of one to five million dollars
the fastest
is a paid off house and steadily
investing in their retirement accounts
okay it is not borrowing as much as they
can on their house and investing it in
the stock market
very few millionaires like less than
five percent claim that they leveraged
their house their personal residence to
build wealth as a matter of fact if we
asked them if they did that they looked
at us like we were nuts
okay now here's how you also would know
that that's true because you are using
good common sense in your thinking
you're asking us but you kind of already
know what you're going to do if your
home was paid for
and you had three hundred thousand
dollars in your bank account
would you go take out a mortgage
in order to have 450 000 in your bank
account
no same difference
yeah
same exact thing in there
so I would pay off your mortgage today
because it's the fastest right way
towards wealth I would set up a mutual
fund draft for two thousand dollars out
of your checking account and just for
fun just to see what that house payment
becomes how fast that one account is a
million dollars will blow your mind then
if you hate being debt free you can go
get your mortgage later
if it's just well and she she said well
if you want that warm fuzzy feeling and
I looked at her I was like yeah I kind
of do yeah yeah well here's what's
interesting that people don't understand
and but I've been doing this for so
stinking long including experienced it
myself you apparently run your own
business right
correct here's what's very weird
you will make decisions not big ones but
slightly different when you're a hundred
percent debt free than you make today
with a pile of cash
in your business and it will have you it
will cause a because you're going to be
a slightly more bold
you're going to be slightly more
confident a little bit more Swagger in
your step because you don't you're not
looking over your shoulder for the
freaking Bank to take you down you are
in control of everything and you will
make Better Business decisions your
business Acumen will increase and I've
seen it happen thousands of times in
entree leadership clients and I've seen
it happen in myself you know I make
different decisions I am not beholding
to the um the culture what someone out
there thinks because I don't have any
payments and so you know it's like
cancer culture stuff right we're going
to cancel Dave what do you care gonna be
a little difficult I own the freaking
place
you know how you gonna cancel me I own
the Ramsey Networks you're gonna you
know call me up and tell me not to put
me on How's that gonna work
you know so you know it's not gonna work
it's not gonna changes and and therefore
I get to continue to tell the truth here
on the microphone instead of being
virtue signaling for somebody else's
agenda autonomy this here's the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today she was
with me in a jam-packed sold out
Building Wealth live event with Rachel
Cruz and George camel and I and
indieapolis last week this week I'll be
in sold out Austin Texas thank you
Austin we appreciate that I will be
there with Ken Coleman Dr John deloney
and Jade wash all right that's right
you'll be with us again in Austin so
there we go and you can catch me at the
other Building Wealth live events the
next one will be April 24th Salt Lake
City Rachel Cruz George Campbell
Christina Ellis and May 2nd in Anaheim
California with me Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman and Christina Ellis a few
tickets left to Anaheim a few more left
for Salt Lake City they both will sell
out early all of our events for the past
two years well the past many years have
sold out so check it out and smart
conference is back and we're going to be
kicking it off at the brand new Ramsay
Events Center here on our campus 2500
Cedar it is almost sold out just couple
of tickets left it's April 14th and 15th
it'll be a full Nashville weekend I've
talked to some of my friends in the
music Biz oh yeah they're going to be
some name people turn out and we're
going to celebrate the grand opening of
the Ramsey Event Center with the new
smart conference all the Ramsay
personalities will be speaking we're
going to do a Friday broadcast from the
stage we're going to do a Friday night
music event we're going to do a Saturday
all day teaching you about every area of
your life from mental health to marriage
to boundaries to money to anything you
want to talk about we're going to be
talking about it and uh it's going to be
a great weekend and we just recently
announced our money and marriage
giveaway a chance for you and your
spouse to realign and celebrate your
marriage that'll be here in Nashville
October 19th through the 21st with Dr
John deloney and Rachel Cruz wow guess
where that'll be and the Ramsey Event
Center so check it out lots of stuff
Happening Here on the campus we want you
to come hang out with us it's also free
to drop by and watch the show and time
you want to do that and so we'd love to
have you do that lots of free coffee and
cookies and stuff from our Cafe here and
the Baker Street Cafe so check it out
ramsesolutions.com events for tickets to
any of those things suggest you check
them out and come out and visit us
looking forward to being with you guys
in Austin in uh just a matter of hours
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you that's exciting all right
Samantha is next in Sacramento hi
Samantha welcome to the Ramsay show
hi I'm so excited to talk to you guys
you too what's up
Alexander and got a life insurance
and for guidance on how to set up my
will
um how to allocate that money
um and I was hoping you guys could give
me some guidance okay you married
no I'm single a single mother of two
boys and my main thing is there's such a
huge age Gap my oldest is 18 going to
school and working right now and then my
youngest is five okay how much life
insurance did you buy
I got a million dollar policy okay what
do you make
uh about 90 000. good for you okay what
do you want the uh hundred thousand
dollar a year income to go to
so
um I have a family mother member who
would take on the responsibility of my
youngest
um but I don't want to leave my oldest
kind of like you know high and dry I'd
still like to be able to give them some
things you know when we're not there and
then you know at the time that my
youngest is older like where does that
balance of that money go to as well
gotcha okay
well the uh most thorough way
it's a little bit more trouble to set up
but the most thorough way the most in
the way it's going to do the best is a a
trust
okay and so like let me give you an
example when our kids were minors our
life insurance first went to Sharon or
if she died it went to me but the
secondary beneficiary went to the
children's Trust
okay now that that's evaporated because
our children are not miners anymore okay
but um but this is how we had it set up
in your case it's just going to be your
primary your main beneficiary is going
to be the children's trust okay
Samantha's children trust you just give
it a name and you have that set up with
your will and then here could be an
example of the terms of the trust so the
money for the life insurance is left to
the trust the trustee that manages the
trust has to follow the guidelines of
the trust you can name a family member a
lawyer or a bank to be the trustee I
would recommend the family member or a
lawyer
okay banks are stupid and so uh but if
you did this then you could say okay the
18 year old can have up to
250 000 I'm making this up okay three
hundred thousand dollars to go to
college
but only if they're going to college
I'm not going to support his cocaine
habit
you follow me so you can dictate very
specifically the trustee can only
distribute the money to the 18 year old
to use for higher education and that
encourages them to go get a degree okay
if you wanted to do that that would be
an example if you want to just give an
18 year old 300 Grand you can that's got
a little bit of danger attached to it
can we agree on that
yeah for sure okay but you could also
say by the time he's 25
you can also build it in the trust at 25
If he if he if you live until he's 25
seven more years the trust automatically
just gives him 300 Grand
which would be fine at 25 I'm fine with
that but at 18 I want to give him a
little bit more guidance okay that's
just me you can set it up however you
want you get to make this up okay then
let's say you took 700 000 and the
trustees guidance was to get with a
smart Mr Pro and put the money in good
mutual funds and the mutual funds were
to make oh say around 10 to 12 percent a
year then you say I'm going to take
seventy thousand dollars a year and
distribute it the the trustee is to take
seventy thousand dollars a year which
the 700 should make right invested uh
distributed to the TR the care of the
the guardian of your child
for just for child support just to take
care of them
if that minor child needs a car when
they're 16 they could make a
distribution up two
twenty thousand dollars or whatever and
if that kid has a major medical event we
can take a distribution to cover the
major medical and if that kid wants to
go to college when they're 18 we can
start taking distributions for that
okay but other than that they live off
the income
and the youngest already is going to
have child support from his um yeah but
that doesn't matter you're Distributing
this to take care of your youngest
that's what you're doing that child
support's over and above that or that
could influence the amount that you
leave to each kid I don't care I made
that up I was kind of assuming the
little kid needed more money than the
old kid who's got a job and is like
going to be an adult stuff but you you
do it however you want to do it right
but once you leave it in the trust then
you just you can really you can comb
that trust down into the finest of
detail
I wanted mine mine said four types of
growth stock Mutual Funds growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international with at least 10-year
track records my trust stated that it
had to be invested that way and if the
trustee didn't do that they were liable
oh okay in great detail
and uh and the things that I just
outlined is exactly what our kids had
it's like major medical you can pull
extra car you can pull a little gr and
higher education you can pull a little
other than that you live off the income
and uh explained all that to the family
member that would have been taking care
of them they said great we're gonna have
plenty of money to raise them and if
there's an emergency we got a backdrop
and if they live if everything lives out
perfectly they're gonna have really nice
money when they get out of college now
Dave if somebody doesn't have a trust
but they have a very clear will and it's
stipulated it what's the difference
there why is it uh in this case the the
will will not manage money over a decade
it'll only manage the distribution of
the will when someone dies are they the
assets when someone to a decade so a
will doesn't I mean over any you don't a
will is a short-term thing for at death
here's what happens a trust is that over
life everything happens over a longer
period of time here's what happens a
will won't distribute money to someone a
decade from now I think that's really
important to note not just for Samantha
but for anybody listening why the will
is great to have but won't cut it over
the Long Haul yeah and this trust was
never formed it was built out but it was
only to be formed upon both of our
deaths in our case so you never needed
it so in Samantha's case she lives until
the child the minor child grows up and
the 18 year old grows up she may end up
just canceling this life insurance
policy because they're both
self-sufficient they don't need her at
some point financially speaking and
that's probably what's going to happen
but your your life insurance is for your
worst case scenario and so none of that
occurred our will all those Wills are
burned and all those life insurance
policies are gone yeah for us this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America hey if you
are enjoying this show and we're a help
to you you can pay us back
because it's free by the way so thank
you for doing that but you could help us
in other words we would appreciate the
help there's a couple things you can do
one is if you are a YouTube or a podcast
follower you can subscribe
hit the follow button the Subscribe
button the more people that subscribe
the more it raises it to the top in
things that they recommend and then
people find us more and more and more
and more and more thank you for that we
appreciate that please do that you can
leave a review a five-star review if
you're not going to leave a five-star
review don't bother your mother said if
you had anything nice to say don't say
nothing at all so uh thank you very much
you troll somewhere else but uh you know
leave us a nice review leave us a follow
a subscribe and the other thing you can
do is you can share the show
Maybe
uh you are listening on talk radio tell
someone where you listen you're watching
us on TBN tell someone that you see us
there you are listening on a podcast you
can share that with a shareable link uh
same thing with YouTube you can share
that with a shareable link share the
show with someone review the show and uh
subscribe and follow to the show how you
do that in talk radio it's it's an old
thing it's called the memory button on
your radio and you memorize the station
it's some of you don't even know how to
do that anymore but but uh if you're if
you're a radio person then that you can
just reserve the station as a memory
number one on your radio and then you
can know to tune in this time when
you're hearing us
um by pushing that number one button
right there on your radio so that's a
throwback dude that is a throwback it's
really let me tell you when we first
started in radio that scan button you
understand and it would jump from
Station to Station until you heard
something you half-like
um that was our best promotional tool
for a while
random people stopping with the scan
button wow don't get that much anymore
all right let's go to Hunter in Tucson
hi Hunter welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve how can we help
so I'm currently 20 years old I'm going
to school for cyber security no debt
cars paid off and everything and my
uncle works at a tech company and they
have an openings for an I.T security job
now I'm not sure if I were to get hired
should I um withdraw from school and
work full-time there or if I were hired
if they could work around my school
finish my degree I'm currently a
freshman
have you found out if they would be
willing to work around your degree
well that's the thing I'm not quite sure
yet if I were to get hired and I asked
and they said yes that's wondering if I
should does your uncle own the company
no he works he's a contractor oh he
works as a contractor okay yes um okay
if they will pay for your school
and let you do school I would do it
but no you're 20 years old go get a
degree in cyber security that's going to
be a gold mine it's already a gold mine
Big Time need six jobs for every person
applying out there and the pay is going
up every second while I was talking your
income went up and
um potentially but you you're you're not
there you're not valuable yet
you don't know squat yet
um you you know a little bit of squat
but you don't Know full squat yet so you
go ahead and work on I don't know if you
need a four-year degree but you need the
certifications and I'd love for you to
have some experience so Ideal World is
they pay for your education they let you
get it and you work there and get paid
too boy that's right just go through
that for sure
but quit school cold with one year or a
half a year under your belt and go be a
security analyst
uh I'm hiring security analysts I'm not
hiring you
I don't believe you yet you follow me
yes sir I don't mean that insulting well
he hasn't had any experience he hasn't
had any schooling yet I mean and so I'm
not I'm not going to put the security of
Ramsey Solutions Network in your hands
right so you know you need to you need
to earn the chops to be able to do that
and educational do that or experience
will do that or in the tech World a
certain program a certifications program
will do that I don't care but uh I need
to know that you know
because I'm as an owner all I know is I
can't spell I.T
okay that's all I'm sure of but I know
people try to crash it every day oh yeah
and I know we got quite a little team of
um anti-hackers around here security
people who uh ward off the Russian
robots every day oh my God they're real
and yeah it's uh the the stuff that
happened but yeah yeah so do you're in
an excellent field very good brilliant
choice of career stay with the career
and do what it takes to get the chops
whether it's a long four-year degree a
certification program or experience or
some combination of those three things
four-year degrees in information systems
are not as valuable these days as
certifications and experience Because by
the time you finish the four-year degree
all the programming has changed
it moves at the speed of light it
changes every second every time I buy a
computer when we get it out of the box
it's already obsolete
it's just like oop that one's dead yeah
they just hit they hit the red button
and it no longer works I had an opening
for the Apple well it's now useless
that's what it amounts to yeah so as
soon as you do then there's something
else that's better 30 seconds later and
AI is going to help us accelerate every
bit of that right oh my goodness so here
we go game on Karen is in San Jose hi
Karen welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you better than we deserve
what's up
okay
um I'm my husband and I are thinking
about taking out a reverse mortgage on
our home please don't process please
don't okay okay
you wanna know why
yes
very high fees
ridiculous interest rates
yes it's uh fourteen thousand to get it
and 10.2 or three interest rates just
almost like I knew what I was doing who
figured you know that's there you go
right there none of that and I know it
yet we know it's dead and we don't have
any debt it is and your home is paid for
no we just had to have it appraised for
the reverse mortgage and it came in at
uh 2 million point three is it yeah
no we owe 385. oh wow what's making you
what made you get to the point to where
you were even considering this
because we didn't want to touch our
retirement that's about a million two
why because every time we take something
out we have to pay more taxes on it and
um the taxes are getting to be a drained
it's about a thousand dollars a month we
pay quarterly taxes yeah so we thought
we'd have what's in the house
are you ready
81 and 84. don't let that scare you
we're very very active I'm not scared of
you at all karen
okay here's the thing here's the thing
don't let the Tail Wag the Dog and when
you make financial decisions basically
only on taxes and the rest of the deal
sucks
that that's the tail wagging the dog
I hate taxes as bad as you do but not
bad enough to do something stupid
and ten percent and fourteen thousand
dollars is in the stupid Zone you've
almost got your house paid for and
you've got a lot of Peace around that
you don't have to worry about where
you're going to live you have a
wonderful property in San Jose freaking
California that's a wonderful real
estate market you're just I mean you
made so much money on this house while
you've owned it please just enjoy the
ride
okay and pay a little pay a little taxes
and enjoy the ride
okay so it's okay to take a little bit
every now and then for a like supposed
to
post a thousand dollars you take it out
of your retirement then you have to pay
taxes on it if you if you do that and
you add it all up how old do you have to
live before you run out of money what's
your me and two invested in
uh the the portfolio yeah um stocks okay
so what's it making is it making 10 or
12 percent
no no we lost about 20 minutes not this
year not this year overall what's it
making yeah it was making about seven to
eight percent okay so let's pretend
let's pretend you're at an 80 000 of
your income can you do can you pay your
taxes and paint your house
yes because you do have an 80 000 you're
eight percent of a hundred thousand
so and by the way you'd have to live to
180 to outwork this formula
so you're okay don't take out a reverse
mortgage
they're bad really bad this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day Matthew 20
26-28 but among you it will be different
whoever wants to be a leader among you
must be your servant and whoever wants
to be first among you must become your
slave
for even the son of man came not to be
served but to serve others and to give
his life as a ransom for many
Arthur Ashe said true heroism is
remarkably sober very undramatic it is
not the urge to surpass all others at
whatever the cost but the urge to serve
others at whatever the cost
there it is Michelle is with us in
Tucson hi Michelle welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi I am so excited I cannot believe I'm
talking to these days around these
imagine how I feel
underwhelmed but how can we help
um so we kind of got ourselves in a
pickle that's probably all your callers
right
um
um so we
did the day we did the financial piece
years ago and then I am afraid to say we
kind of fell out forward we had a couple
moves a baby
um and so anyway we um please don't
shave me but we bought our house
um a couple years ago and uh
bought a solar release with well it came
with the house
um
I tried to call
um recently because we're starting up
Financial Peace again because we need to
kind of you know get back in the game
and we found out I tried to see if we
could buy out the lease and
unfortunately there is no buyout option
and so I don't know what to do now as
far as like going through the process
again and do you have any documentation
on this
I do okay
have you attempted to read it
yes is it Gobbledy
now they pointed it out on the line
itemy that we cannot buy out our lease
and how long is the lease
we have another 15 years on it and we
bought the house
two or three years ago so it was already
two years into the lead and they
transferred it over to us so you're
paying for solar panels for 15 years
here
unless we sell the house then either we
have
an option to transfer over the lease to
the next owners or we can
pay off the lease at that point you can
pay off the lease now if you paid all
the payments for 15 years but I don't
recommend that
I asked them that they said that we
cannot oh absolutely you can they can't
stop you from doing that but they don't
have to give you a discount
that's what the line item means so that
that's that's not legal but um
what's the full amount
um I want to say I don't know the papers
in front of me but I just looked at them
last week I want to say it was about 20
000 left around there through the whole
15 years
yeah yeah so it's over a thousand
dollars a year
okay yeah for those of you out there
considering solar panels let this be a
listen to you
either pay cash for them or don't buy
them okay
um I'm big on solar because the the
current technology on the new solar
panels is excellent especially in a
place like Arizona
uh you can they actually work they gotta
they have a break even period of about
three to five years and if you pay cash
for them it could work out you got to
really run the math and make sure in
your area it will work but in your case
you just got screwed by the by the by
the the crooks in the Solar industry uh
because this is crooked I mean this is
it's not it's not technically crooked
it's not fraud but it's immoral
uh to stick somebody in something and
with absolutely no Escape methodology so
I don't know what to tell you
um
what's the house worth
um we bought it right before the
um
um I believe when we did it it was about
I want to say fives okay 500 000 house
and a twenty thousand dollar problem
what's your household income
um about a hundred thousand every year
so I you can just put this stupid in the
budget if you want to just a line item
you pay it monthly or annually
monthly yeah just put it in the line
item stupid just put stupid in your
every dollar and just just just pay it
every month that's one thing you can do
and then just not worry about it again
just call it a day uh because here's the
thing if you give them twenty thousand
dollars now we know that 15 years from
now you're probably not in this house
so that was dumb to pay it off that way
with no discount okay because had you
invested the same amount of money
gradually over a period of time it's a
lot more than twenty thousand dollars
so I would rather you just take your
money and live about your life and just
write this down other than that if you
want to spend a few hundred dollars and
go talk to an attorney and have them
write the Solar Company a letter and say
if you don't discount this and let these
people out for a reasonable rate uh
we're going to make some kind of
problem for you I don't know threaten
them because it's just wrong it's
ethically wrong with what they've
trapped you into but it also was stupid
so you can put it in the line item as
stupid in the budget I will accept that
I'm not shaming you I'm not shaming you
because I've done stupid a lot bigger
than a thousand dollars a year I promise
you I've done a lot bigger stupid than
that so this is fairly minor in the
scope of your life it's just but what's
frustrating on your behalf I'm
aggravated because you're stuck I don't
know a way to get you out
yeah I'm upset too and I will never I
will make sure yeah why don't you call
the consumer affairs division at the
State of Arizona and ask them if they
have any suggestions
okay and uh they may have uh they may
have dealt with unscrupulous solar
companies before and uh that they may
have a loophole that has been put in
that the company wasn't willing to tell
you I don't know I really don't know of
a way but I'm just fishing around so you
know you can have an attorney try to
smack them upside the head you could
talk to the consumer affairs division
see if they know a loophole in your
state maybe they passed something like
for instance another rip-off that
Arizona has done a good job with is
timeshares timeshares are legalized
fraud
okay and and Arizona has got some good
legislation on the books to smack the
timeshare industry around like it needs
to be it needs to be smacked around
because they're screwing people left and
right usually old people and so they get
most often and so yeah that but
Arizona's done a good job with that so
maybe they did a good job with
unscrupulous solar but let me just
highlight one more time I am not
anti-solar right right I'm not
anti-replacing the windows in your house
but taking payments to replace the
windows in your house in order to save
that much on your electric bill because
you have a more efficient window is an
absolute scam don't do that
and solar panels is not something that
you could
resell like purchase resell or not all
move to another not all ones because
right there it's like a computer think
of technology has gotten better every
year on it and so old solar panels are
about as much junk as anything you can
think of wow they're totally useless I
don't know how old these were she said
two or three years old they're maybe not
that old but the current technology on
solar is excellent if you get top of the
line stuff yeah uh I mean we've looked
at it we endorse them in several markets
but not with payments yeah not with a
lease
I'm not yeah that's I'm so sorry I'm
sorry you got in that Michelle I wish I
could help you I wish I'm aggravated
partly just because I don't know what to
do to help you but there you go there
you go so good luck with it hun
yeah
um when you're making decisions what's
the moral of the story from Michelle's
caller when the stupid things I've done
in the past same thing
when you're making decisions slow
down
slow when it comes to wealth not making
mistakes
and doing good solid Investments and
decisions
slow is fast
the best way to get rich quick is don't
get rich quick
and that's you know that's what we talk
about around here all the time and most
of the mistakes I've made is when I get
in a
I get my little hillbilly butt in a
hurry and I run off into a mess and I
I've done it too all of us have done it
but slow
down and then you don't step in a bear
trap like that that puts us out of the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]